on est aujourd'hui à madrid madrid pour
avoir le lancement de chez omis de
nouveaux smartphones et on est plutôt
pas mal arrivé hier soir il ya une début
de soirée avec tous les journalistes fcc
i praille prat cool on va les découvrir
les smartphones je vous emmène avec moi
bien évidemment on va aller voir les
coulisses on va les voir ce qui se passe
on va aujourd'hui par les chiots me
tendant première charge regardé comme
d'habitude ils ont fait un petit tour de
ma piaule d'hôtel on est situé dans
madrid regardez-moi ça on est à l'hôtel
marriott mêmes ont dit deux petits lits
séparés
bon bah ça m'a évité de métal et de
rupture à quoi ils parlent de la beauce
et c'est là où je posais la caméra vous
voyez quoi pour bosser petit poids pour
peser la valise juste la vue extérieure
était plutôt mignonne on continue ici
qu'est ce qu'on a
bon bah minibar et compagnie ça j'y
touche pas on mérite c'est tout le monde
hop
ici les grandes salles de bain avec une
grande douche je regardais mois 50 sur
ses marchés historiques assez bizarre
pour va mouiller ce truc est bon pour
croire que non dequidt wallet voilà on
d'aller se faire une belle balade et on
la vivait le trouve sympa non
[Musique]
la classe à dallas ne suis pas prêt est
pas prêt regarde moi ça les chaussures
rouges le style quelle honte à
chaussures elles sont dégueulasses
mais il faut pour saler l'avez peut-être
oui mais j'ai la flemme tu vois qu'on
est robuste et vous le ferez espagnols
ou des lieux de la ville ça va je marche
fixé fait très mal au fait y avait
failli repartir
ça m'a dit lève toi et marche séjour
séjour dit si ce n'est pas nous qui
allons bien voir dans quelques temps
l'écran là y'a plein de monde les mii
fans et nous on m'a dit tu fais tendent
à table tout ça non pourquoi vous êtes
tous
on est cassé à maroua
la baraque
je me vient de présenter un nouveau
smartphone c'est leur ennemi note 8 et
nouveaux smartphones dont je vous ai
parlé il a hier d'ailleurs juste bien
j'ai sorti la vidéo sur le minott dit
cela on a ce nouveau smartphone et demi
note 8 et qui est un peu
successeur du renmin obsèques a beaucoup
marché qui a eu beaucoup beaucoup de
succès et la du coin que ce smartphone
on peut aussi avoir un truc extrêmement
intéressant pour se retrouver à l'avant
qu'un grand écran de 6,3 pouces dali ps
un écran lcd j'ai mes notes là je
connais pas tous partagent donc j'ai
voulu faire comme ça lcd san écran avec
une résolution de 2340 par 1080 pixels
ratio 19 points 5/9 à 409 pixels par
pouce
on a à l'avant comme à l'arrière un
corning gorilla glass unc plus de
résistance conséquent même devenir le
protéger si vous voulez éviter les
déconvenues voulait éviter que votre
smartphone se pète la gueule ça quand
même relativement bête on aura sur écran
face avant de 88,3 % on a quatre
capteurs à l'arrière alors celui des os
et un 8 mégapixels c'est l'ultra grand
angle avec un champ de vision de 120°
une caméra en dessous de 40 8 mégapixels
pour pouvoir lutter avec plein pixels
avec la techno 4 pixels en 1 100 euros
quatre gros pixels ça vous fait un seul
même et qu'on fixe est pour capter plus
de lumière le troisième juste en dessous
la regarde elle c'est pour la profondeur
de champ c'est 1,2 mégapixels qui vont
servir pour le mode portrait pour les
fai de bloquer et le petit dernier
servira pour faire de la macro si vous
voulez aller regarder ce que nous a
montrée sur la presse un pareil pas
complètement dingue tout sans regarder
si quelques jours le temps de faire le
test prendre en main dial connaître et
je donnerai mon retour très rapidement
sa vie donc à vous abonner aujourd'hui
c'était pas des briques et à l'avant
vous avez une caméra de sel filles de 13
mégapixels tout ça tourne sur un
qualcomm snapdragon 665 on a une grosse
batterie intérieur de 4000 millions
terreur pour durer un jour et demi voire
deux jours ça aussi je vous le dirai
lors du test de la recharge rapide 18
watts qui inclut directement dans la
boîte avec vos smartphones
on a de l'infrarouge sur le dessus une
prise directe sur le dessous du nfc et
une version 4 gigas de ram 64 go de
stockage que pouvait monter jusqu'à 250
giga pour le tarif
cadets ils nous ont mis large les pris
en photo ou le tarif est marqué la gelée
prieur de la presse 199 euros il va être
dispo à partir du 13 novembre dans
toutes les bonnes boutiques - je trouve
en tout cas sur le papier plutôt
intéressant le règne de sept avaient
cartonné très bien marché c'était un
excellent rapport qualité prix d'entrée
de gamme on va voir ce que ça va donner
avec ce raid mines
suite et il en vient complexifier les
non atteintes et pourquoi pas on a un
menton qui assez proéminent
on voit bien la marque rémy et on le
voit également à l'arrière donc on se
dit est ce que au final rémy est pas une
marque forte pour xiaomi parce que sur
les nouveaux smartphones de chimie vous
marque xiaomi directement et ils vous
marquent pas ennemis tandis que la voix
bien mark herr et demi au lieu de
marquer shiomi c'est un choix de la
marque pourquoi pas je sais pas ça vous
intéresse qu'est ce que vous en pensez
vous de ce modèle est ce que ça pourrait
vous tenter j'ai beaucoup parlé du rpt
et demi note 7
on a souvent demandé qui a été le
meilleur rapport qualité prix d'entrée
de gamme est très clair - rémy no27
marchait parfaitement bien celui là
semblait en tout cas intéressant je
trouve ça pas mal
ce design avec le dos en verre comme ça
il ya des reflets c'est assez joli le
fait d'avoir ces quatre caméras alignés
ça me paraît pas mal aussi
capteur d'empreintes digitales dans
cette gamme de prix forcément on va le
garder ici à l'arrière pour l'instant on
n'a pas son écran mais c'est pas très
grave grand écran qui me paraît bien
rien de bien dingo ensuite au niveau du
smartphone il paraît intéressant on en
reparle d'ici quelques jours à vous nous
dire comment vous le trouvez en bas en
commentaire qu'est ce que vous en pensez
est ce que vous vous êtes client de
schumi est ce que vous pourriez le
devenir
avec ce modèle là d'un des mandalas
groupe qui a eu lieu juste là je monte
sur scène
vous avez la presse derrière moi tout
était là le public c'est pas mal quand
même hein je pense que c'est quand même
relativement appréciable de retrouver la
regarde et mettez vous à la place de la
personne qui présente vous n'avez les
petits prompteur ici parce qu'il faut
bien savoir quand même ce qu'on raconte
vous voyez le public en pattes ça fait
un peu de monde c'est quand même un tour
de force de clyde fait recette presque
personne comme ça on va jeter un petit
coup d'oeil
parce qu'il ya eu d'autres produits le
présenter lors ya une télé mais a priori
on leur apprend france pas si vous me
voyez
un peu de gloire la télé n'arrivera pas
en france il ya des chemins qui a des
bagages le guet de classiques 20 pouces
je sais pas du tout ce que c'est
bon allez voir ça ça c'est du produit
écosystèmes sorte de la valise shiomi
ils font peu touchée celle de la valise
elle vous montre comment s'est fabriqué
bon ok ça le principe pourquoi pas et
voyons là ici la fia au mileu gates
classique vaguement propre tic valley
c'est rigolo
regardez je vous parlais de la télé on
as salam i télé qu à 13 55 pouces dont
vous avez la fiche d'éclat mais surtout
vous avez la télé qui est pas mal
caleiras atteinte alors je vous dis on
leur a pas en france mais son principe
salaire quand même assez mignon petit
pied cadre assez fin pour les envoie le
son là c'est un peu fort quand même pas
mal non ça a l'air pas mal
je me demande si ce produit arrivera en
france parce qu'à mon avis ils
arriveront france suis là je peux qui
fonctionne
[Musique]
que faire des faits bré transition
s'avère qu'ils ont tellement bien avec
youtube haramboure incroyable je me sens
un peu perdue dans l'aéroport j'ai
l'impression que personne ne sait où on
va pour repartir
il ya tout le monde qui repart par la
voilà à bas les voilà mais ya que
stéphane qui sait où il va toi tu sais
où tu vas toi paris paris bravo mais est
ce qu'ils paraissent est beau cet
objectif donc repartir sur paris petit
avion tout à l'heure et puis voilà finir
monter tout ça pour que vous l'ayez
demain mais puisque vous le regardez
c'est que bien d'où la vie des gens bon
voilà penser tout pour cette journée
c'est lancement de smartphones ce n'est
pas ce que vous en pensez pièce tout on
va partir le temps de manger un bout
d'embarquer regardez dans les clics avec
moi les copains ça les gars ça cacher ça
et ça vous a plu ces smartphones ou pas
leur parle du raid me nots 8t shit et à
l'heure du thé la chair bien et
bon projet pal mal pas mal pas mal pas
mal samarie qui va faire la différence
esprit es tu sais quoi
ça c'est beau ce que tu viens de dire
voilà je pense qu'on va rester là dessus
merci c'est le prix qui fera une chance
merci au revoir sur ce je vous embrasse
ton rendez vous dès demain est là chez
moi toutes vos questions et réactions
tout ce que vous avez envie aux
commentaires et puis voilà on fait des
gros bisous bisous